so
as i told you before we started and i
hinted at here so i came from the
progressive world i've been i now view
being progressive basically as a mental
disorder or something
and but i consider myself classic
liberal which really really is
conservative
in a lot of respects it's libertarian
essentially yeah it's technically
defined it's conservative or libertarian
so i'm somewhere
in there um and it seems to me that that
the republicans
if they would stick with what are
supposed to be their principles that
you're talking about
they would have a much better argument
than what they have right now and that
they don't
stick to their argument right that's
part of the problem well i think that
what's happened is as government has
gotten larger it turns into this giant
grab bag of cash and so what you have is
a bunch of constituencies in the united
states who
are dependent on these grab bags of cash
i remember i was i was down in palm
beach florida for uh for a conference
this must have been five years ago
and uh and linda lingle who was then
running for senate in hawaii uh was
former governor of hawaii republican she
was she was speaking at a synagogue and
i was there and this little old lady
palm beach a very rich area this little
old lady toddles up to her
pearl necklace diamond earrings and she
walks up to her and says what will you
do
to keep them from cutting my social
security
and i thought to myself who are you like
you paid 50
into social security when you were 35
and you're probably getting out 3 000
a month now but because people have been
made that promise they're now dependent
on the government so what do republicans
do
republicans say no no no i would never
do away with social security right we
would transition it or we would save it
once you get into the business of the
government takes care of you in your old
age
now we're just arguing over methodology
we're not arguing over morality
my view is that people have been made
promises we have to keep those promises
because otherwise we just have too many
people who
have no source of income you make a
promise you keep a promise but
if you are under a particular age no
social security at all take
i want my money back okay i'm getting 15
of my salary taken
every year to be put in a fund that i
will never see again
again i have one child and i have
another one on the way i would much
prefer
to put that in a sep ira and just let
that grow with the stock market by the
way you want stock market to boom take
all the money out of social security
and put it into companies on the stock
market you want to see an actual
economic growth curve
that would do it as opposed to
pretending that it's in a lock box
somewhere that doesn't exist when
they're just rating it every two days
for
the lock box never existed never gore
said he had the lock box there was no
there was no lock box it's a ponzi
scheme all right so to the left though
because i'm with i'm with you on that
that they're not they're sort of just
not holding to their principles so what
i've seen in the left
is that most people went from being
liberal and then
somehow over the last couple years
they've become
these social justice warriors and
they've divided everybody by what
all our differences are of skin color
and religion and all that and they've
picked a pecking order
of who's the most aggrieved and the
victim hierarchy
the victim hierarchy and because of this
uh
it seems to me that it's just there's no
end to it that that's what scares me the
most about the ideology
is there simply is no end game with it
because ultimately
it has to eat itself because then one
day you'll fight for everybody else and
then they'll come around and they'll
come for you i mean this is what's
happening on college campuses right
college campuses are about as left as
it's possible to be
except that the leftists are now eating
their own right they're going to the
administrators and saying
you're all micro-aggressing us and we
need trigger warnings and it's white
privilege and they're ousting people who
who were protesting in these buildings
40 years ago right on the left and
they're getting them fired now i mean
lauren summers was was
clinton secretary of the treasury i was
at harvard when they threw him out right
and they threw him out because he made
the politically incorrect statement that
maybe there weren't that many women in
the high reaches of science because
women didn't
want to be in the high reaches of
science or it's possible there weren't
enough women who were qualified for that
and they threw them out for that i mean
what's happened i think
is that we've reached a point we're the
wealthiest society in the history of the
world the people here are the wealthiest
that any people have ever been and we've
also
forgotten that there's a ex there's any
sort of ideological existential threat
this
i was four when the soviet union
collapsed so people my age and younger
don't remember the soviet union they
don't they don't recall it it's not
important to their lives
and when they think of socialism they
think of kind of the happy dappy
socialism of denmark
they never look at the tax rates but
they think okay everything's going okay
in denmark they forget forget the fact
that we've paid for denmark's national
security for the last half century
forget the fact that they're not having
to cut their taxes forget the fact they
just elected a conservative government
to keep out the islamic wave that's now
swamping them
all those things go by the wayside so
what happens is that all these people
kind of live off the fat of the land we
all do
and then rip away at the foundations
because when you're living in such a
rich society
and you look at for example income
inequality and you say there's some
people who are earning
millions of dollars and there are some
people who are earning tens of thousands
of dollars
what we forget is that in human history
and in human society
the difference there there's seen
millions of dollars and tens and tens of
thousands of dollars
and then there's where people have been
historically which is here right and
when you rip away the foundations
everybody's gonna end up down here you
can't just take all of the founding
principles
of small government and free markets and
rip them away but what's happened is
when young people are always looking for
a reason to fight i mean
we want to change the world that's our
thing changing the world when the
world's pretty good what do you change
we've basically changed a lot of the
external circumstances and now the
question is
you're rich you live a pretty free life
right so what's wrong
only what i feel is wrong what's in here
is what's wrong and so it's become a
very feelings based society anything
that's said to me that hurts my feelings
is now no longer just something hurtful
it's a microaggression right and
i can actually reach out and i can harm
you i can i can ban you i can call the
police if you hurt my feelings
the university of missouri there was
actually when this whole thing was going
down there was
there the university of missouri police
department put out a notice if somebody
says something to you that's racist call
the police department
yeah right 70 there's a poll that just
came out that 70 percent of
college students are comfortable with
hate speech codes on campus
40 of college student of millennials
people aged 18 to 34
40 of them believe that speech that's
offensive
to to women or minorities should be
banned
in the united states across the board so
some of this though that young people
are just kind of
dumb like the world is going to teach
you some stuff and when you're at
college
you're going to be kind of dumb i had a
guest on a couple weeks ago michael
shermer who said
that their all this microaggression
stuff and all of this free speech stuff
as
horrible as it sounds to us right he
sort of was arguing that in a way
you could say this shows the progress
because instead of having to fight for
actual things
they're fighting for these feelings and
not that he was for that
but it shows you that we've progressed
and that you know that black people
aren't fighting
so that they have separate water
fountains they're now fighting over
things that may that are just about
feelings and that's obviously a lot
it's a testament and you're right it's a
testament to the progress but i mean to
go off what you were saying 50 years ago
black people were fighting to not have
separate water fountains
and today they're fighting to have
separate water fountains right i mean
they actually want separate black
housing
at usc they actually wanted a separate
black safe space
at university of missouri this is
dangerous stuff and what's more
dangerous
is an entire political hierarchy that
benefits from this because
now you've got candidates who benefit by
telling particular interest
groups and racial groups you're a victim
we're going to help you out the way
we're going to help you out
is by specifically calling the rest of
the society racist you're a victim
forever
and the longer we can make you feel like
you're a victim the more you're
dependent
on us right well we'll just go i mean
hillary clinton was doing this in harlem
the other day she's saying
yeah we haven't cured racism in the
country and that's why i'm going to take
hundreds of millions of dollars and pour
it into harlem
as though nobody's poured hundreds of
millions of dollars into harlem before
right the only dollars into harlem that
are actually going to matter
are police dollars to clean up high
crime areas so that investors will go in
the reason that businesses aren't going
into high crime areas is because they're
high crime areas and just dumping money
and they're ain't going to help anything
so so
you would agree that racism exists of
course right that there are people that
are legitimate racist
it would be idiotic to to think
otherwise of course there are legitimate
racists and we should target them and we
should find them and we should hurt
their careers because
racism is unacceptable but what i don't
agree with
is this i don't like fighting phantoms
as i said earlier institutional racism
is a meaningless phrase libraries are
not racist schools are not racist you
have to show me a law
a policy a person who's racist you can't
just say american society is racist
because that doesn't mean anything
show me the actual problem that we can
discuss because when you just throw
tautologies out there like that
what am i supposed to do i mean there's
no way to fight that there's
legitimately no way to fight that right
so i discussed that with larry elder
who's
conservative but on the libertarian side
and he basically
said what you just said and i think some
of my progressive friends would say
well it may not be institutional anymore
and that there are
laws that existed no longer exist but
they would say well
uh certain communities will get less
because of racism just because of the
idea of racism
will get less qualified people to teach
and that they will be treated
differently by the police and all of
those
by by income level that's true but it's
true by income level it's not
a race and income level tend to
correlate unfortunately but but that's
that's more to do with income level than
it has to do with race it's not like
there's somebody sitting in sacramento
today in california
going all black community we're not
putting anybody in there i mean the real
the real
gap in the country especially between
rich and poor is two parent
households not race i mean the poverty
rate in the black community for two
parent households is seven percent
the poverty rate in the white community
for for a single parent household is 22
percent so larry said that to me also
that same thing and he got a lot of hate
for it and then i got lumped into that
yeah because people
so i'll just go with you on that for for
the purpose i mean a statistic yeah yeah
so
i'll trust that you're giving me a fair
statistic yeah that's a real statistic
so okay so
so fair enough but that that enrages
people there's there's something about
that concept i think that really upsets
people
and you would say that that's really
because of the feeling well yeah this is
my catch phrase goes facts don't care
about your feelings i mean the reality
is yeah
exactly this is as as we move forward in
american society the only thing that's
going to cure the ills that we have
is looking at some of the real problems
straight in the face i mean the fact is
that
when welfare was instituted in the 60s
before it was instituted the black
single motherhood rate was 20
that is now in excess of 70 and it's not
just it's not just impacting the black
community it's impacting the white
community
right the white community used to have a
five percent single motherhood right now
it's in excess of 40 percent
okay the fact is you're going to get
higher crime you're going to get more
poverty
it's the brookings institute which is a
left institute right i mean
it's a liberal institute the brookings
institute and they kind of straddle that
line between liberal and left
they say that if you don't want to be
permanently poor in the united states
you need to do three things and three
things only
graduate high school get a job and hold
it don't have a baby before you're
married
that's it and by the way those things
have nothing to do with racism
right there's not a white person there
let's there are very few
i would be hard-pressed to find a black
person in america almost straw man
yourself there well right
i'd be hard-pressed maybe there is one
maybe there's one yeah
i don't know how many single black
single mothers got pregnant because a
white man was holding a gun to a black
man's head and said i want you to
impregnate this person then leave okay
the single motherhood is a decision
that's made by the people who are
involved
in the sexual act and what happens
afterward and it's the single best
predictor of general intergenerational
poverty
so make good decisions so so it's really
the issue that when the left doesn't
deal with these things honestly
that then they're just handing it to the
right i mean i see this we've been
talking about this a lot
related to all this stuff with islamism
because the left
calls everyone a racist so anytime me or
any of my friends that are talking about
this there's not many of us on the left
every time we bring it up i mean i'm
getting called a big left and right now
and yet they can't i say well can you
point to something bigoted i've said or
something racist said they can't
but it's a feeling they feel offended
they feel offended but is this where if
the left doesn't deal with
something so you know you can talk about
islamism or if the deaf if the left
doesn't deal
with the roots of income inequality as
you've laid out that you just hand it to
the far right ultimately right i mean
doesn't this sort of explain trump to
you a little bit
i think well to a certain extent i think
that that's right i think that what
happens
is that there is a and i would never
justify
people reacting in racist fashion
because you know you can react in
reasonable fashion to stupidity
people say silly things like single
motherhood doesn't matter and i say no
single motherhood absolutely does matter
but what people tend what some a certain
segment of the population and this is
true both on the left and the right is
when they when when somebody says
something they don't like they
immediately go to
racism i mean i can't tell you the
number of tweets i've received after
after i said that i don't like donald
trump
that's when the anti-semites come out of
the woodwork and it's and it's bizarre
to me like
it's it's like what is what does my
jewishness have to do with not liking
trump
as far as i'm aware his daughter's an
actual convert to judaism right so
it's it's weird but it's but um yeah and
i think that
it's it's polarizing the debate in a way
that need not we're not we're not trying
to solve problems anymore in american
politics all we're trying to do is
demonize the other side and
turn them into the bad guy and so my
goal is to demonize the people who try
to demonize
right those are the people who ought to
be demonized if your goal in politics is
to just
make character attacks without regard to
facts then i'm not interested in
debating you on on facts because you're
clearly not interested in debating on
facts yeah so that's
that's a good subway because i read your
11 rules debating a leftist
and i just read i read the entire thing
this morning okay
it's pretty short but it's on my mind
and basically everything you said
i was struggling when i was reading it
because i was like ah i'm agreeing with
all of this because i still consider
myself liberal and there is a part of me
that i don't want to
read something by a guy that's
conservative and do i agree with this
stuff but
a lot of what i saw in there are the
exact tactics that i've seen this
regressive left
use on me and use on you know sam
harrison all these other yeah exactly
that's right
relentlessly so you really gave the
antidote to some of these things so you
don't have to lay out all 11 but you
want to pick some highlights because i
think there's some really interesting
yeah i mean
a lot of them kind of kind of turn into
okay so i'm trying to remember all
eleven off the top of my head really
yeah give me a couple so so the first
one is that you have to embrace the
fight you have to understand going in
that you're in a fight
usually and you have to sort of
determine the purpose of the
conversation that you're having
this is basic and this is true if you're
left or right actually determine what
your goal is
is your goal to convince the person on
the other side is the person
open to being convinced if not you're
wasting your time uh is
are you on a show and there's an
audience in which case you're not
speaking to the person you're speaking
to the audience
and once you determine that understand
that if there's hostility you have to be
ready
to punch back twice as hard you have to
and and be preemptive in that attack
which by the way you say that's a left
idea these are all left ideas to punch
back twice as hard yeah i mean it was
president obama who coined the phrase
right
he was the one who was saying that his
supporters ought to punch back twice as
hard
and i've sort of hijacked that because i
think that it's actually an effective
tactic and necessary
i've also said that one of the that it's
important
at the very outset to ensure that the
framing of questions
is proper because one of the ways that
the left succeeds and you see in the
republican debates particularly
is they'll ask a question and then the
republicans won't even
bother to try reframing what the
question is so john dickerson the other
night and in the cbs debate he opens up
with
and he tries to browbeat ted cruz on you
say that nobody
should be confirmed in the last year of
a president of a president's run
isn't it true that the constitution says
the president gets to pick the nominee
and cruz instead of just saying john i
don't
care about the timeline i don't know
what you're talking about we're not
going to confirm anybody who doesn't
agree with scalia
instead of just saying that and it's not
our obligation to do that the
constitution has many provisions john
you know
instead of just reframing the question
he he sort of bought into it
and you see that from from a lot of
these from a lot of republicans they
just accept the question as it comes to
them
rather than thinking there's there's a
second question that's usually kind of
embedded in the first question that's
being asked in most in most debates so
those are a couple examples there's also
you don't have to accept
the you don't have to accept the the
kind of hero worship that
so many republicans do one of the
frequent ones that you do is somebody
will say well ronald reagan was for
amnesty
why do i care right i was i was two when
you know when we needed amnesty
like you want to talk about regular or
when when people try to misdirect to
bush
they don't like you're saying something
about obama so they say something about
bush
so your proper answer should be fdr
woodrow wilson
william howard catholic you want to talk
about bush we'll talk about bush we want
to talk about obama we'll talk about
obama
like let's stick to the topic at hand so
a lot of
my basic rules for debate can basically
be boiled down to two which is
get the character assassination off the
table
if they're going to call you a racist
sexist bigot homophobe the proper
response is not
no i'm not a racist sexist bigot
homophobe here's all the proof that i'm
not
it's no you're a jackass because you
have no proof of calling me that and
accusing people of things without
evidence is the mark of being a jackass
yeah right and that's that that is the
proper response and then once that's all
off the table
then we can actually have a policy
argument so what do you do about people
that don't stop doing that i i had some
leaves
you just let it be because you leave i
mean you say this is not a worthwhile
debate you're an and i'm leaving
right there's there's no there's no
purpose to to
but sometimes you know you think that
not picking up the fight and this would
be whether you're on the left or the
right whatever whatever fight you're in
that sometimes by not picking up the
fight you actually are strengthening
them
no i mean because i think you're
strengthening here here's the logic
right if somebody calls you a racist
and you say no no let me explain to you
why i'm not a racist
what you're really saying what you're
really saying is you're a rational
fellow
let's have a conversation about why i'm
not a racist yeah by even granting
the predicate you're a rational fellow
he just called you a racist
right if you say to me i'm a racist and
then i say well you're a rational fellow
i'm saying to you you're right i'm a
racist you're a rational fellow calling
me a racist a rational person
could theoretically think i'm a racist
no the answer is that's an irrational
thought you're being irrational what
you're saying is
is ridiculous and you're a bad person
for for dropping charges on me without
evidence only bad people do this
if you're going to drop a charge make
sure you can back it up well that's the
thing i find that there is an incredible
lack
of being able to back it up and there's
a constant i don't know that you address
this specifically
but i find in a lot of these debates
when i have these debates with people
there's a constant moving of the goal
yes so you say something and you sort of
get the point across and they
they can even if they don't outreally
accept that it is
they intellectually do and then they
just move what they say and then they
just keep moving and moving it and then
you're you know you're back in a circle
right
i say and i do say in that pamphlet that
arguing with people on the left is sort
of like trying to nail jello to the wall
and then the minute you finish one
argument they're already on to the next
and
they're usually swiveling to places that
they're more comfortable like same-sex
marriage or social issues because
that those are those issues closer to
the heart so they're more comfortable
for them to argue
and so if you're arguing economics
invariably you find yourself talking
about why republicans are mean to gay
people or something it's it's
it's always a shifting goal post because
you can't get and if the left this is
what i like about sanders
i think sanders will actually give
honest answers to questions if i say to
bernie sanders
bernie what constitutes income equality
forget income inequality like what
gradation would it be income equality
does everybody have to earn the same
because there's a name for that right i
mean if everybody earns the same the
only way to do that
is to confiscate all wealth and
redistribute it that's called communism
right
i think that sanders would would
actually answer that but most people on
the left won't they'll just move the
goal post and
right what do you think he would
actually say i think what he would
probably say is he would say the sort of
income inequality that we see in europe
is is
is more beneficial to the to the united
states
and you say well okay that requires a 60
tax rate it means the car
literally the prices of your car will
double because they have massive excise
taxes over in denmark
and you know if that's something that
you want to do you're also going to have
to
you know raise taxes on the poor raise
taxes on the middle class you're going
to have to
gauge the fact that every business in
america is going to leave
which is not going to be pleasant for
you are you willing to are you willing
to build here's the thing about bernie
sanders economic policy
donald trump wants to build a wall to
keep people out bernie sanders will have
to build a wall to keep businesses
in because they will leave right he will
actually have to chain them to a stake
in order to keep them here but i mean
speaking of businesses leaving and all
that
did you see this piece this week about
alan grayson from florida
he's been a lot i mean he's been
lobbying basically for companies that
have money
offshore in the cayman islands or he's
not lobbying as an elected official
right now because he's not elected right
this second
but that he's been doing this for years
and this guy is a progressive hero
and he's doing the exact same stuff that
bernie would tell you is literally
the worst thing you could do and i
pretty much agree with bernie on that uh
so it just shows you that their their
heroes aren't even lined up in any sort
well that's true too i think
yeah i think that's the case